hi everyone welcome to the daily
homeroom live stream sal here from khan
academy for those of you who are
wondering what this is
this live stream is something we started
as soon as we saw schools starting to
get closed around the world because we
saw well we can support folks with all
the content and all the software that we
we put out for free we started running
parent teacher
webinars
and we said look in a time of social
distancing it would be pretty cool to
have a place where we can feel connected
where we could talk about interesting
topics some of them relevant to the
crisis some of them may be allowing to
get our minds out of the crisis so
that's what this is and i like to remind
everyone we are not for profit we can
only do this work and everything else we
do because of philanthropic donations so
if you're in a position to do so please
think about making a donation i do want
to give a special shout out to several
corporate partners who've stepped up in
the last few weeks especially when they
saw our costs go up because of the uh of
the of the crisis uh
bank for america google.org fastly 18t
end of artist and i also want to thank
the many other
philanthropic and corporate partners who
allow khan academy to do what it does
with that said we were running at a
deficit even before this crisis and we
continue to run into deficit because our
costs have gone higher all that support
has really helped
but we still need more so if you're in a
position to do so please think about
donating so that many many millions of
folks around the world can continue to
benefit from from this work
with that said i have a very exciting
guest today we have adam brown is
joining us from new york he's the
associate professor of psychology and
director of trauma and global mental
health lab at the new school for social
research so you can imagine what we
might be talking about today so adam
great to have you here
thank you sal it's so nice to see you
and and to connect with you today
yeah and and just to remind everyone uh
you i think you already get a sense of
the topic we're going to be talking
about mental health we're going to be
talking about resilience we're going to
be talking about neuroscience so if you
have questions about any of those things
now or during our conversation please
put them on the youtube or the facebook
message boards we have team members who
are looking at those comments and
they'll surface them to myself and adam
but adam you know before we even jump
into the questions i think we have a fun
connection
that uh uh uh between us uh the famous
nadia uh that uh many people know was
the cousin that i started tutoring when
i was 11 when she was 12 years old i was
in my 20s um you have now taken over as
her advisor
[Laughter]
and have been so fortunate to have come
into
her world and to be able to work with
her over the last couple of years i
don't have to tell you how remarkable
nadia is but the fact that she you know
has that connection to all of your work
is just really wonderful um
i had just hired nadia as a research
assistant when she
she just graduated sarah lawrence and in
the commencement address uh someone
brought up your name
um and mentioned that a sarah lawrence
graduate had been the first student of
khan academy and i said hey that's nadia
that's that's so great um
and she's and i'll talk about some of
her research today but um yeah it's been
great to be connected to her your family
and now to be able to talk to you today
now one of the most common questions i
get is whatever happened to nadia and i
always call up nadia's like there's a
lot riding on your success now because
if you're the first student
you're the the uh no but but i think
that's that's a really fun connection as
you mentioned she is now working with
you and thinking about things like uh uh
you know neuroscience and and mental
health so so let's you know just jump
into it you know a lot of you know when
i read your bio you talk a lot about
trauma and post-traumatic stress
disorder before we even go into how do
we deal with these types of things or
what might cause it what's a definition
for these things we hear a lot we hear
the words thrown out but what does it
mean in your
your sense you know that's a really
timely question a lot of people have
been asking me what is covid19 is this
traumatic is this just stressful um it's
hard to know we're actually conducting a
survey right now with thousands of
people across the world
actually trying to answer that question
in terms of how much it disrupts
people's lives how long is this going to
impact people
to what degree is it going to impair
people's ability to focus to do their
work to be caregivers
and i think one of the things that we're
seeing already is no doubt a lot of
people are feeling very stressed feeling
overwhelmed
but at the same time people are being
able to maintain abilities to connect
with one another to engage in their
schoolwork
to care give for family members and to
friends
and in terms of definitions um one thing
to think about
are different kinds of symptoms that we
see different types of changes in
thinking and behavior and emotions
that somehow reflect the kinds of
adverse experiences people have and so
when we think about
stress we tend to think about
increases in arousal people's
fight-or-flight responses kicking in and
when we think about trauma we tend to
think about more long-term lasting
negative changes uh people having
memories that are really upsetting to
them
behaviors where people might not want to
think about talk about
or revisit places that were really
difficult for them and then maybe
feeling really jumpy startled and easily
agitated by reminders of that thing that
made them upset
and
one of the things to keep in mind is
we're in this really strange moment
where it's you know covered 19 continues
to unfold uh so the whole notion of
post-traumatic stress is based on this
idea of an event is over
and then we kind of see how people adapt
and respond to it and one of the i think
uniquely interesting and challenging
things is that we need to find ways to
support each other throughout the
different phases of this
and some of these phases i think are
going to be stressful in ways that other
phases will feel you know challenging in
other ways
and so yeah i would argue that in many
ways this is a sort of collective trauma
it's going to be harder for some people
than others no doubt
um but i think we'll also see a lot of
people emerge quite strong and resilient
from it um especially if we put into
place certain support systems and
practices uh throughout this time
that's actually a fascinating definition
because i think in kind of i always had
a colloquial sense of these words but i
think that so stress is something that
physiologically you feel it you can even
observe it but it's has a short term
phenomenon you know
a year later you might not be able to
detect either in yourself or in someone
else that they went through that stress
with trauma there will be some
manifestations of it
and what i like to tell people is that i
mean the goal of life in general and the
expectations is that not to never feel
stressed one of the most ancient
hardwired things and probably most
universal thing we share in just about
every species is this fight flight or
freeze response that when we perceive
threat or danger
our body almost unconsciously prepares
itself to either run away to attack or
to camouflage itself and we share this
mechanism this has really evolved to
keep us safe for a long long time
the key is not to feel stressed
what i would love to see teachers and
students and parents and other community
members doing is thinking about ways we
can support each other to come down from
that stress you know this is going to be
a moment where we hear something on the
news if we have a conversation with
someone that ramps up that stress level
that's normal that's natural and it
tends to be temporary but then we need
to have other practices in place to help
us come down from from that response and
part of what nadia actually has been
working with me on is actually to target
certain parts of the brain that kind of
do that you know there are inhibitory
neurons without getting too scientific
too quickly that actually signal down to
our fear centers of the brain to say you
know what you're right that was pretty
stressful that was really a you know
fear-provoking response let's come down
from that now that's not an immediate
threat that we need to deal with
so that is one way that i like to think
about the difference between stress and
fear and maybe something more
long-lasting like trauma
and so what are what can you do to you
know what you just described is
fascinating that there are these
inhibitory neurons how do you get them
to inhibit the stress response or
and i guess a corollary question is how
do you
know whether
what's going on inside of you is
you know a healthy stress that we all
feel
versus something that's getting worse
than that
that's a really good i think to the
second part of your question to me i
like to think about duration and
intensity so all of us i mean everyone
listening in today i mean if you're
anything like me you know first of all
you're going through a rollercoaster of
emotions every single day right now
there's so many unknowns there's so much
that's unpredictable
and at some point in the day you have
that feeling of fear or worry about
what's happening in the world i think
what we all want to be paying attention
to is the frequency in which we
experience those kinds of emotions and
the intensity how much are they
disrupting our ability to concentrate to
get tasks done
to be a caregiver to take on the
different roles that we assume
and if we start to notice that they're
happening more often and that we're
really unable to do the work and play
those roles in our lives that we need to
that's when we might want to start
thinking about where do we get
additional support how do we get
additional help right now to take care
of ourselves and others
how do we engage those parts of our
brain to send those inhibitory neurons i
think the nice thing is there's lots of
ways to do it there's no one way but one
of the things that we're learning is
that there's parts of our brain
especially something called the dorsal
lateral prefrontal cortex the dlpfc if i
could have a favorite part of the brain
it's pro that's that's up there because
what we've found that it does is that
when we're looking at something really
scary and we reinterpret that as
something less threatening less
dangerous
something we can contextualize and adapt
to
that seems to be the part of the brain
that we recruit and engage and it has
those neurons that kind of send back
down to parts of the brain called the
amygdala
there's a lot of ways to engage it we
found a lot of good evidence that
things like mindfulness-based practices
are really good
we also find that when people are
engaged in things that they're committed
to that they're really focused on where
they're really not thinking about the
past or the future but they're really
just involved in that work uh we seem to
really be able to tap into the
prefrontal cortex in really important
ways
and specifically the ways we've done
this with nadia to bring her back you
know into this uh she and i have done
some really interesting studies where we
have people recalling memories
uh where they think about times they've
overcome challenges and adversity and
then apply those lessons learned to the
current moment now of course covet is
unlike anything we've ever experienced
but we've found that when people recall
memories of mastery and overcoming
adversity that subsequently seems to
help people engage that part of the
brain when they're confronted with new
challenges so that work is ongoing but
it seems like an exciting way that we
can deliberately target that part of the
brain right now
and what would you say is a common
thread here i guess maybe first it might
be useful for folks to just you know you
mentioned mindfulness that's a word that
people might have heard before what does
that mean to y'all and i guess what
aspect of that
do mindfulness meditations or whatever
do you think is is doing the trick here
there's so many different ways to engage
in mindfulness and for those who are
less familiar with the concept we know
that from various practices whether it's
meditation
whether it's
something called progressive muscle
relaxation techniques where you just
kind of slowly tense up different
muscles and relax them whether it's
things like yoga
whether it's even taking a long walk you
know slowly any practice in which you
are deliberately engaging in slow
diaphragmatic breathing you know belly
breathing where you're really not
thinking about the past you're not
worrying about the future and
importantly you're not judging yourself
for how you're feeling you're just
allowing yourself to recognize whatever
is going on in your minds whatever is
going on in your body and just allowing
that to be and then kind of allowing
that to pass
what we've seen almost across the board
is that people who spend even as little
as 15 minutes a day engaging in these
different kinds of practices
show quite a bit of reduction not only
in terms of our perceived levels of
stress but also some really great
neurological benefits as well and
mindfulness won't cure everything but at
a moment where a lot of things feel
really unpredictable and we might be
pretty hard on ourselves as students as
teachers as family members
this is certainly a practice i've been
recommending to people um as we need to
be very self-compassionate and kind of
focused on the moments where the big
picture is so full of different
variables
just you describing that i started
breathing a little bit deeper i i
started tensing and relaxing some
muscles and i started thinking about the
present and not caring
not one cell that one's on me
it sounds
sounds sounds good you know there's
something you touched on
and there's a question here from
facebook which which is interesting our
salon ansari asks can stress be
beneficial sometimes because you did
mention that there might be aspects of
this that make us more resilient
yes um in a couple of different ways and
if we think about stress as a motivator
there's certain kinds of stress that's
particularly helpful
what we want to think about in terms of
stressful experiences or things that we
find intellectually engaging so i think
you know thinking about the classroom
what kinds of activities give our
students a sense of purpose
meaning
and direction
at the appropriate level so things that
are challenging but not boring and not
overwhelming in which they feel like
there are you know either teachers
parents others who can scaffold that
experience for them um but that really
directs them towards inactivity and
towards problem solving
that kind of stress is really good
stress and the really cool thing about
it
is that we actually see neural benefits
associated with it
for example we know that mildly
stressful challenges for young kids in
the earliest stages of development are
critical for brain growth
and similarly across the lifespan when
we look at older adults who take on new
challenges that are somewhat
uncomfortable but they have to really
stick with it like learning a new
language maybe picking up an instrument
it's pretty difficult at first it can be
a little stressful but that commitment
to learning that new task
actually can support brain health in a
lot of really important ways so the idea
and i should also say
there was a great study done by dan
gilbert at harvard a number of years ago
where he would text people and say what
are you doing right now and how happy
are you and frankly when people weren't
doing anything
they weren't very happy
when we're just mind wandering and we're
not really paying attention to things
we're not so happy but when we're
engaged when we're focused when we're
challenged at the right level it's a
little stressful but it brings more
meaning it brings greater levels of
happiness and i think ultimately does
make us more resilient
that's fascinating and you know you
mentioned for very young children that
these mild stresses are actually
essential for brain growth what are
examples of those mild stresses
i think about you know a lot of the work
that's gone into social emotional
learning with kids where the idea isn't
to tell a child exactly what to do but
you put them into more open-ended
scenarios where the child gets to
explore on their own the way they might
use materials the ways that they might
problem solve you know i'm thinking back
now to my kids when they were two and
three and having their first classroom
experiences and just watching them
negotiate social relationships even at
those very very young ages you know
sometimes that's kind of messy and it's
kind of a little difficult but through
those interactions through them trying
to really discover how to work with
materials you know i'm sure you know
with your kids as well you see this
really wonderful mastery type thing that
happens when kids are challenged and a
little bit stressed where they might try
the same thing over and over again until
they really get the hang of it like
going down the slide or being on some
kind of equipment that's kind of
challenging at first
we see kids really playing that out a
lot of scenarios that ultimately i think
in part why we see that investing in
early childhood education is so
important is because kids are really
getting to experience the stress that
comes along with that but then being
able to resolve it and ultimately
overcome it in that practice that
process again and again is so important
for long-term well-being and good
educational outcomes
and that's very consistent with a lot of
what we talk about you know we talk
about mastery learning and students
being in their kind of zone you know
right at that learning edge slightly out
of their comfort zone but not too far
out of it so it makes a lot of sense
it's very much i think you know for
anyone who uh does exercise or trains or
weightless there's a obviously a very
strong
analogy with what happens with your
muscles when you when you stress them
obviously you don't try to lift 500
pounds you know your arms might fall off
that's not good that's trauma
but if you lose if you're able to lift
five ten maybe twenty maybe you know
whatever your zone or proximal that that
actually can put some positive stress
and and you you grow so it sounds like
there's a a very strong um a lot of
parts of our body work that way i guess
is one way to think about it so that
we're getting a lot of questions here on
uh well you know from youtube wade asks
what are ways you can recommend to
encourage someone suffering from
depression to adopt helpful habits in
this time of remoteness
that's such a good question one of the
biggest things that i would like to
emphasize is that we still we've come a
long way i think with even you know sal
even even the fact that we have this
space right now to talk about mental
health i think signals that there's a
greater openness to talking about these
issues in ways that a few decades ago we
never would have been sharing in this
way so that's already a great sign and
we need to go even further though i
think to really destigmatize what it
means to be a person suffering with
mental health issues
one of the things that i would recommend
is to really think about talking to
people about that mind-body connection
that when we're feeling down when we're
feeling depressed or really sad
it's not only taking a toll on us
mentally but we actually know there's
quite a bit of brain science to show
that it's taking a toll on our bodies as
well that our immune systems our
neurological functioning all of this in
some way is being impacted by depression
and what's really interesting is that
when we see
people getting help and getting support
not only do we shorten the length of how
people how long people are depressed but
we actually reduce the number of times
in their lifetime that they also have
more episodes of depression
so i know there's a long standing
feeling like depression and mental
health is something that's hard to talk
about with each other but to be honest
the sooner we can open up with each
other if we're struggling and the sooner
we get support for it the shorter it
will be the less intense it will be the
reduction in impact on our bodies you
know we'll ultimately see
um and and i think ultimately um you
know those kinds of folks will be
showing fewer of those negative
behaviors so just maybe try to have
those conversations around both the
physical and mental sometimes that's a
really good weigh-in
and you mentioned these supports you
know i obviously there's the you can get
true support you can go to a be able to
get you know medical help go to a
psychologist like psychiatrist
is there a spectrum of other things you
know are there other activities that
someone could engage in that could help
you know habits
yeah absolutely so what i like to think
about mental health is i mean if you
look at the statistics almost everyone
in the us for example at some point uh
will either experience a mental health
issue at some point or know someone that
does it's about one in five adults it's
roughly one in six kids the numbers are
pretty staggering
but that doesn't mean that everyone is
experiencing very severe mental health
issues and there will be times when
people do need that more specialized
care but i think there's a lot that we
can do for each other especially right
now to help us whether some of these you
know anxieties and depression that we
might feel i mean a couple of really
basic things that people can be thinking
about are not even the mental health
things but our brains crave routine you
know to the extent that we can be
structuring our days in ways that mimic
life pre-covet would be really really
helpful
making sure that you get enough sleep i
mean i can't tell you how many studies
come out that say if there's one or two
things you can do for yourself around
mental health is to get a good sleep
habit good sleep hygiene not only
reduces mental health issues following
trauma but also helps people bounce back
even faster if they've been through some
kind of upheaval
social support is probably one of the
biggest i mean there's a lot of really
interesting genetic studies for example
showing that people might be more or
less sensitive to different kinds of
stressors but if they have good support
systems not thousands of you know
followers but even two people that they
can reach out to to say hey can can i
get some help with this right now can we
talk a little bit we see dramatic
buffering of stressors in people's lives
if they've got a few people
that's especially true with kids there's
a long history of research to show that
children growing up in really difficult
circumstances if they have one adult one
caregiver in their life that they can go
to they'll they tend to do significantly
better over time and then i would say
the last thing is just having something
in your life that brings you a lot of
joy a lot of meaning that you can really
stay committed to throughout whatever
else is going on in your life so those
are some of the common elements that we
see that can really support people uh
even you know in addition to or separate
from therapy
that's super helpful i think people hear
a lot about sleep but i think what you
just said super you know underlines it
even more like don't think of it as
something that is a nice to have it is a
must-have and having even that one
person ideally more that you can just
open up and and support you uh that's
that's very tangible and i think doable
for for hopefully a lot of folks from
youtube and g is asking
what do you recommend to help kids who
are a bit negative in outlook especially
when faced with a challenge even
slightly out of their comfort zone
that's a really great question
and sometimes those kinds of thought
processes are a little bit hard to shift
but there i would get back to that idea
of mastery and experience and you know
sometimes just having a conversation
with an adult or a child you know you're
not really going to convince them that
working on a task or taking something on
is going to be good for them or fun or
meaningful i think it has to come
through experience and thinking
creatively about what kinds of
activities you can give them even if
they're skeptical
to try and through that process
you know come out of that with a feeling
of accomplishment
one thing that i want to emphasize there
is it's not only the experience of doing
but it's also the feedback that kids and
adults get after the experience
and what i mean by that is we have seen
in several studies now that when you
reflect back to someone i noticed that
you did that well or you know i saw that
you stepped up in that particular way i
was really impressed that you did that
we actually find that that kind of
social feedback actually makes people
more resilient better emotion regulators
after the fact
when they get that kind of social
feedback so for everyone now you know
interacting with others whether you're
living in close quarters or you're far
away from each other
just to be thinking about the words we
use when we point out to each other i
noticed that you know you really handled
that well i saw the way that you were
you know taking that on that actually
instills a sense of positivity and
resilience in others and so that might
be another way to really you know help
with that negative outlook i think that
combination of doing and social feedback
is really critical
no i take that feedback to heart i even
think about even in work you know
sometimes i get very
task oriented and i'll talk to a team
member i was like hey
we're doing this by this afternoon right
what is it and i and i think i need to
take a step back especially now but
frankly always and make sure i i'm
appreciating the things that i i am
appreciating but i'm vocalizing it and
something you you you know you just
mentioned it even reminds me of some of
my interactions i've been having with my
11 year old lately where it's actually
the roles have been reversed we've been
playing a lot of chess and uh he's
getting quite good
some of my my fatherly ego is being uh
and so you know sometimes when when he
has an unusually good movement i'm like
okay he has a peace advantage and i i
feel like quitting and sometimes i just
like okay you got this game and then
i've seen that he never quits he
literally even if i have an advantage he
will keep playing and i've said okay
you've inspired me you've taught me
because sometimes he actually comes back
and um
he's actually teaching me that but
hopefully by me praising his
his his resilience his grit uh that that
that he's building that skill outside of
out of the chess board
so i guess related to that muhammad
ibrahim from facebook is asking how can
we make students deal better with
mistakes when when to tolerate them how
they benefit the best for making
mistakes instead of losing their
confidence that's a good question i mean
we hear about growth mindset mistakes
and failures when you grow but as a
parent sometimes you know you knew that
when they were going to pour that milk
is going to end up in a disaster
so i'd like to offer a slightly
different interpretation of that or
maybe suggestion that maybe others
wouldn't um
i would say look to your parents your
teachers
other relatives that might be you know
in your life
that kind of um flexibility the you know
coming back from mistakes is something
that we've all gone through and one of
the things i don't think we do enough
you know as much as we spend time with
each other is to really share in those
kinds of stories and one of the things
that i've personally found to be
unbelievably helpful i try to do this a
little bit with my kids certainly do
with my students also is to actually ask
them to go back and to find stories of
our elders of our family members of our
teachers our role models that we connect
with and to find out from them you know
when they went through something that
was really hard and maybe they made a
mistake and they had to bounce back from
you know to kind of
think about that perfectionism that a
lot of us carry around how did other
people manage those challenges and what
we actually see from some research
studies is the more we know those
stories the more we're able to connect
with the mistakes and the successes of
people in our lives the more we can kind
of say to ourselves wow you know i'm
connected to that person i can't believe
they went through that i can't believe
they overcame it
that kind of helps to contextualize what
i'm going through
and kind of understand it and frame it a
little bit different there's the power
of those intergenerational stories are
unbelievably helpful i think um in
dealing with those kinds of mistakes
that all of us will experience at some
time
super profit advice and some of the
hopefully the benefit of this live
stream we've had you know some folks who
are titans of industry and it looks like
they've just did everything right in
their life but to have here you know i
asked them questions about times that
they were really you know had made
massive failures and a lot of us would
have been
really
stressed or even depressed in those
circumstances actually i'll turn that on
you adam you have anything to share you
know moments in your own life where
you're just like
well i mean two things in particular one
i tell my students in my lab and in my
research methods class every semester i
hope your studies fail i want everyone
to experience what it's like to design a
study in it for not to work out because
i think from those failures emerge is
often more creative ideas that we
shouldn't be always looking to just
succeed but it's really about learning
from the process and so to me that's app
failure is just as important as success
so much of the time you know i think
about my own career too my career to
being a psychologist was so not linear i
thought i'm definitely gonna do you know
something totally different as a career
and was so sure of it and i was totally
wrong um and that you know ultimately
led me to something i think i love even
more but we have to go at it with all of
our energy and our commitment we have to
take those intellectual risks uh we have
to take them with others you know as
communities in order to ultimately
discover the things that bring us the
greatest meaning and joy um we won't
discover it unless we take those chances
we have to be you know really not only
okay with making those stakes but i
think be prepared for them i see them as
critical to this entire process
that's super powerful i actually had a
conversation with a close friend a
couple of days ago and he was telling me
he's a he's a professional investor and
he was saying that he had one of his
first investments a few years ago just
completely wiped out you know complete
failure it was a disaster on a lot of
levels and a potential investor in his
fund he met that day and he was so
distraught even though you wouldn't
normally tell an investor about
this disaster that you happened he just
opened up and how reflective and that
that when the investor heard it he's
like now i'm ready to invest in you
because i see how you deal with failure
i see that you learn from your failure i
see that you're reflective of it and so
now i think you're ready to manage more
so so i think other people also see that
in you when you they see how you can
when you cope and learn from and grow
from from that failure you know not not
to get too
i guess dark here because this has been
super valuable and we're running short
on time but there's a lot of questions
here and this one is pretty relevant
from youtube susanna garcia domenges uh
asks what is the appropriate way to
acknowledge the people who have passed
due to covet or maybe or even sick
i feel like the debts are minimized due
to due to statistics
wow i could not agree more with that
person so thank you for bringing that
question i mean one of the things that
i'm hoping for and have been kind of
waiting for
um are more
regular moments of mourning and
acknowledgement of all of the people
that have been lost
it's something i think a lot of us are
doing very privately uh throughout our
days but we really haven't had a sort of
national
uh or even state or city level you know
moments there's been a lot of
celebration and recognition of the
heroism and bravery which is really
wonderful to see especially in new york
but i agree i think we need to find ways
to acknowledge and mark all of the loss
and suffering that's been taking place
and just i don't have a great answer but
just to say to that person that your
concern is among the top three or four
things that i've heard from people at
the who for example around mental health
is how are we going to help people
engage in rituals and traditions
that are almost always social in nature
uh that are so hard to do right now um
so just to say that i hear you uh this
is a really big question and even the
experts don't have great answers but for
all those on the caller who watch this
just to say we kind of need all of you
uh to really think about new ways that
we can come together and support one
another in these really really dark
times um i don't think the answers are
going to come from psychologists and
psychiatrists alone i think it's really
going to take a lot of thoughtful
smart and especially young people to
come up with new solutions to
how do we grieve how do we mourn all of
this loss and trauma right now so thank
you for bringing that up
so adam you know we're we're already
over time these conversations go faster
than i ever expect there's so much good
here but this has been really valuable i
think a lot of very tangible things for
folks i mean number one sleep
number two make sure you have some type
of support find people be open with them
and and i guess the corollary to that is
make yourself open to other people be
there for other people who who might be
and you know whatever they're going
through who knows you won't even know
unless you unless you make yourself open
and then you know some of these
techniques you mentioned whether it's
mindfulness and other things
they could be a preventative just so to
make you a little bit more resilient or
especially if you start to feel like
your behavior your thinking is getting a
little awry seek help but also try to
build some more of these habits is what
i took away anything i missed
just to be really self-compassionate and
forgiving right now i mean these are
really unknown you know times that are
unlike anything else we've ever
experienced and i know so many of us
whether we're students or teachers or
parents we walk around with these models
in our head of we have to be doing
everything just right and we need to try
our hardest that's you know of course
but we also need to recognize that this
is you know a new normal every single
day and we are working and living and
caring in ways that we've never could
have imagined a few months ago
so please you know during these times
please be good to yourself be kind to
yourself and others a lot of this is
going to be temporary and a lot of this
will be things that we continue to talk
about you know well into the future
but i do think we need to be
extra kind and extra supportive of
ourselves right now
well thanks so much adam that was super
super valuable and and thanks for
everyone else for for joining uh this
session uh
you know as you see there's just a lot
of uh interesting conversations thank
you everyone for uh your questions and
uh you know thanks for being thank you
for being part of this live stream and
we will see everyone tomorrow at the
same time
you